first I have to congratulate you on the
massive success of your Memoir thank you
this is going to be a best-selling
author
that's what it feels like
um it's amazing you know because that
that book that Memoir took two whole
years wow to write and I wrote it during
the pandemic actually thought of the
idea during the pandemic and then I was
like okay it just keeps going this
pandemic keeps going let's let's do it
let's do it well the world ate it up
there was a lot of talk about the sex
goals of course in this book I mean now
I'm like geez Tamara well the thing I
wanted to know is like you know without
getting too personal like okay how are
you and Adam doing with your goals we're
doing well okay and did you finally read
that part no he did it
you know what it is because I think
we're just doing it because you're
living it yeah we're living it do you
know what I mean I feel like a lot of
people can relate to that because I feel
like when you are in a successful
marriage as long as you two have been
I'm sure you constantly asked what's a
secret boom there it is right there yes
especially
are essential
partner and hopefully they can you know
reciprocate that now did your parents
and sister and brothers kind of skip
over that part in the book or do they
kind of they have not and they have not
said anything to me but I will tell you
I am very I'm open to uh my sister my
brother my mom my mom is like okay boo I
see you uh T is like get it girl my
brothers they're like ew no I don't want
to hear this this is gross
yeah well speaking of family we actually
spoke with Tia last month she was
glowing and lovely as always you know
despite obviously all the changes in her
life but do you notice a change in this
new era absolutely I told her I said Tia
I'm looking on your Instagram this is
the happiest you have ever been in a
long time
a lot of other people you could be
falling in love with
but you're choosing you
glowing and I said you look different
really but in a you know a very positive
way it's not like
no it's like oh my gosh you look
beautiful and I think it's because no
not I think I know it's because she is
living her authentic
true self and I think that is what
everyone should should do and it's not
easy that's the thing right it's not
it's scary and I told her I said you
know what I'm so proud of you because
you are showing other women hell even
men you know that you walk in your truth
look look what happens no matter what
and she's the voice for for so many
right now and uh you know she has her
days you know good days bad days
um but she's very very strong and uh
aspiring plus she's got an amazing tribe
behind her right I feel like when you're
going through something this dramatic
it's nice to have your family in a good
support system yes the Maurice don't
play yeah we don't I love it all right
let's talk about these TV projects I'm
gonna start with the first one okay
Hallmark movie Yes inventing the
Christmas Prince a grand piano yes a
reindeer make a snowman come to life
that last one shouldn't be too hard
first of all what was your reaction when
you read that script and why was it the
thing that you had to do okay
okay another Hallmark film and a baking
show and I was like I'm tired
but I read it and I was like I have to
do this yeah it is so sweet I love
playing a mother I know there are some
actresses out there who are like no no
no I don't no I absolutely love it
especially in a holiday movie yeah oh
come on
um and Izzy Birch she is such a talent
she's so much fun I have a
seven-year-old daughter she's eight and
I think she steals every single scene in
this film and I am here for it it is
sweet adorable funny emotional because
this is a mother who has lost her
husband
and she's a single mom now right and
she's been telling this story you know
four years and it is her goal to keep
her daughter happy around the holidays
and I can relate to that as a mom I'll
do anything to keep my kids you know
very very happy but um also this is a
woman who has guarded herself from love
because she experienced heartbreak yeah
so this story you know
shows that you can love again
you have to heal and allow yourself to
do so let's talk about the other big
project you're hosting baking
competition show right Dr Seuss baking
challenge
two teams ready to get bacon
we're trying to like take it home
so it's Zeus I would eat this here or
there I would eat this anywhere
Dr Seuss fan growing up I mean
absolutely my favorite uh memory of Dr
Seuss is I was in kindergarten and my
kindergarten teacher read to us green
eggs and ham and we actually had green
eggs okay and ham in class
I don't know what she used to make the
eggs green nowadays that probably would
have been such a little food dye I don't
know if it was healthy
um but it was it was good and uh I think
this is Amazon uh Prime's first baking
show I have hosted a baking show before
I love to bake yeah so this was a good
fit it's it's yeah it's a dream but what
I love about this one is that you
actually have
um cake artists and pastry chefs okay
what's your favorite holiday treat to
bake with the kids well I love baking
sugar cookies chocolate chip cookies
apple pie
peach cobbler I think that's my
husband's favorite and you know I baked
it once I was like let me just try
because I made my my apple pie and I was
like let me try some peach cobbler and
he was like this is the best I was like
better than my apple pie this is my
first time yeah it felt really good you
know you have said previously that your
daughter was already showing some
interest in acting so dear God I mean
does that worry you does that make you
nervous or excited absolutely she's like
all of the above all of the above
um but here's the thing I want to make
sure that she's doing it for the right
reasons yes it can seem very glitzy and
glamorous you know from the other side
um and yes those are elements of what we
do but at the same time you have to love
the craft that is what's going to keep
you focused that's what's going to keep
you I believe sane so what do we have to
do to get your daughter in the next film
of yours okay so here's the thing she
wanted to be in this last Christmas film
okay that I was in and how I knew that
was I did a zoom call with Izzy because
I wanted to make sure you know that she
knew me a little bit more before we
started filming you know we got to fill
each other out and this was for
inventing the Christmas this is for
inventing the Christmas prints I was on
the zoom call and my daughter comes like
just strolling in and she's like who are
you talking to and I was like
what's happening here she's like I
thought I was supposed to be in this
film and I was like
uh well you know what Ariah let's
practice a little bit more I want to
make sure that you know you can you can
truly do this because this is a lot of
this is a lot of work mama
so she does want to be in in one of my
films but I want to make sure she truly
knows what she is is doing absolutely
absolutely because also I feel like
she'll get the bug she does one movie
she's going to do a second and it'll
turn into a dozen and Mama really will
be busy
foreign